comme le veut la tradition ils sont
venus souligner le premier de l'an en se
baignant dans les eaux froides de la mer
du Nord
mais surprise cette année l'eau est à 8
degrés et la température extérieure à 13
degrés et en même temps c'est quand même
quoi
normal c'est pas normal non ce n'est pas
normal ni dans le nord de la France ni
en République tchèque d'ailleurs
habituellement couverte de neige en
janvier en fait durant les derniers
jours des centaines de records de
température ont été battus dans près
d'une dizaine de pays européens 19
degrés en Pologne et en Allemagne près
de 18 en Autriche au Luxembourg et en
Belgique et 15 au Danemark et au
Pays-Bas
la meilleure illustration le domaine
skiable en France et en Bosnie en ce
moment même réduit comme une peau de
chagrin beaucoup de stations sont
carrément désertes
la vague de chaleur est en ligne avec ce
que les Européens ont vécu l'été dernier
au Royaume-Uni par exemple ou en Espagne
écrasé par la sécheresse cette même
Espagne où il fait actuellement 25
degrés dans le nord du pays
selon certains experts du climat ces
écarts de température figurent parmi les
plus extrêmes de l'histoire européenne
récente ici normand Grondin Radio-Canada
Montréal